Big scandal for the election Miss France The jury
is accused of racism I explain you everything.
Indeed,
the details of the votes have just come down,
namely the jury's vote and the public's vote And while the public had
chosen Miss Guyana and Miss Guadeloupe in 2nd place,
the jury placed Nord-Pas-de-Calais in 1st place and Miss Provence
and Miss Languedoc in 2nd place.
Guyana and Guadeloupe the most popular with
the public and the last with the jury.
This racism kills me So the public's favorite misses are Guyana and Guadeloupe but
because of the jury that preferred the 3 white women,
they lost But it still surprises you Me no,
I knew it,
it's still the jury's fault Or it's the jury
that made miss Nord-Pas-de-Calais win,
she was only 3rd of the public's choice
By the way,
if you're interested,
I'll put all the details of the votes right here.
So is this controversy justified or not?
Tell me what you think in the comments and subscribe
for more videos about Miss France.